está bastante apretada
todos los proyecciones y los sondeos
sobre estos estados es de Resaltar que
Alaska era una carrera entre un
republicano que apoyaba Donald Trump y
otro que no apoyaba Donald Trump por
endesa silla ya se le asigna el partido
republicano en este momento Entonces los
republicanos va en la carrera el senado
tienen 49 sillas versus los demócratas
que tienen 48 sillas es de mencionar
también que si los demócratas logran dos
de los tres estados que están todavía en
juego llegan a la mayoría teniendo en
cuenta que kamala Harris pues es el voto
de desempate los demócratas solo
necesitan asegurar entonces 50 votos 50
sillas y los republicanos tiene que
llegar a 51 sillas para quedarse con la
mayoría en cuanto a los datos concretos
en Arizona el demócrata Marc Kelly está
por encima de la candidata republicana
markel y lidera con un por ciento de
votación versus un 46% de votación y se
han contado un 72% de los votos Espera
que esta noche Se conozca más
información sobre la votación en el
condado de maricopa que es uno de los
condados que más votantes tiene y Pues
de pronto esta noche o mañana por la
mañana sabremos de pronto más
información y nos acercaremos más
a la al al comprar a los datos completo
de la votación en en Arizona en cuanto a
Nevada pues es el republicano que lleva
la ventaja sobre el candidato sobre la
candidata demócrata Katherine Cortés
esta se quería reelegir pero pues ya
incluso hay proyecciones de que Nevada
va a terminar siendo republicano también
y queda Entonces el estado de Georgia
que ya se ya se proyecta que habrá un
desempate en diciembre para definir si
los demócratas o los republicanos se
quedan con este estado que podría ser
bastante importante pues como bien
indica es Cristóbal Georgia votará en
segunda vuelta el 6 de diciembre un
estado que ya en la anterior votación de
medio término fue clave pues terminó
dirimiendo el desempate en el senado Por
qué se divide tanto Georgia entre
republicanos y demócratas y volverá a
ser clave el resultado tal y como
podríamos avanzar
clave y de hecho va a ser según
analistas y
muchos aquí en Washington están diciendo
será en Georgia donde se defina
precisamente la mayoría en el congreso
nuevamente hace dos años se definió
también ahí en un desempate también
entre Rafael y la otra candidata
republicana y en esta elección también
Warner que estará presente en un
desempate que pues se conocerá el 6 de
diciembre es decir hay que esperar casi
que un mes más para saber qué partido va
a quedarse con la mayoría en en el
senado en la cámara alta y lo que la
razón por la cual esto ocurre es porque
pues aunque Georgia en el pasado era
considerado un estado republicano pues
recientemente ciudades como Atlanta pues
han empezado a jugar un rol bastante
importante el núcleos urbanos están
tildando más hacia el partido demócrata
la población joven está votando mucho
hacia el partido demócrata y la
población inmigrante también se ha
tildado más hacia el partido demócrate
esto ha hecho que los centros urbanos a
gran contrapeso a esa mayoría roja
mayoría republicana que normalmente
tenía Georgia y está forzando
precisamente a estos desempates es
importante Resaltar entonces que pues lo
decía antes los demócratas quieren
tienen que asegurar dos sillas una sería
la de Nevada y otra la de Georgia para
asegurar la mayoría en el senado y pues
los republicanos tendrían que ganar
Georgia y quedarse con Arizona también
para lograr esa mayoría